hey guys my name is Jess it is the ninth
of November today and here's the GS News
episode to get you a few minutes closer
to the release of fallout 4 tomorrow
since we're already talking fallouts law
rocket League is adding in special vault
boy themed and tennis you can decorate
your soccer cars with them developer
psionics revealed on twitter that they
would be releasing an update that would
allow all players to equip themselves
with the vault boy themed antenna for
free the fallout Edition comes as part
of today's update which has introduced
mutators that mix up the way you play by
featuring modes that have low gravity or
include different sized and weighted
balls they've also added community flag
so you can pledge your rocket League
allegiance to day 9 reddit and something
awful among other communities Microsoft
has announced the initial lineup of xbox
360 games that will be making their way
over to the Xbox one by a backward
compatibility you can check out the full
100 plus games list on site but the bulk
of the titles come from Microsoft's own
library ads get expect unfortunately
call of duty black ops 2 and red dead
redemption which topped the most
requested games for backwards
compatibility on the Xbox feedback site
are not on the list but Microsoft added
you can expect new Xbox one backward
compatible games to be announced on a
regular basis starting in december more
titles are on the way including fan
favorites like halo reach halo wars call
of duty black ops fire shock Bioshock 2
Bioshock Infinite and skate 3 Microsoft
have also said that all future xbox 360
games with gold titles will play on xbox
one we expect that where fallout Gove
mods will follow but one water has
already created a quick graphics
enhancement mud the model called raped
has created the enhance
wasteland preset which aims to improve
the game's lighting and textures using
the popular sweet FX shade at all since
it was first revealed just prior to e3
the topic of follicles graphics has been
a point of controversy an analysis from
digital foundry reveals that the game
runs at 1080p cross ps4 and Xbox one but
while the targeted 30 FPS framerate is
generally reached it does occasionally
dipped to 20 frames in more dense and
detailed areas in the game they also
reported that the xbox one version
suffers from a stuttering issue which
pulls the frame rate down to zero in
some areas where the ps4 stayed firm at
28 FPS let me know down in the comments
what mods you'd like to see come out for
Fallout 4 and heard the games but we've
got stories on an alien isolation one
which ditches the alien and news on
cyberpunk 2077 that is everything I have
you today as always let me know what
matter to you and I will catch you again
tomorrow